hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are watching
the worldwide reveal trailer on ubisoft
north america's channel for
tom clancy's x defiant um
this is a 3 minute and 30 second trailer
and then
they also have a developer interview
that will watch as well um i don't know
a ton of
about this other than i think i saw a
screenshot
that alluded to it maybe have something
to do with splinter cell
which i feel like is probably wrong um
yeah it seems like a shooter it's my
current impression
i'm gonna guess it's gonna be one of
their first free-to-play titles having
just announced that they're going free
to play
but other than that don't know anything
um i always want things to be good
cautiously optimistic about this
not sure what it is so let's take a look
shall we
let's do it
we're excited to share a first look at a
project we're developing at ubisoft san
francisco
this is our take on a multiplayer first
person shooter
we need to get you in early rainbow six
siege goal is to make a better technique
for you the players to compete and have
fun with your friends
it's fast-paced fire fights meets punk
rock mosh pits i could not tell you how
old that man is our new game
tom clancy's ex-defiant your feedback is
essential to help us make this game
great
later in this video we'll tell you how
it is going to be free to play but first
we'll get into the action
this is a free-to-play high-octane
shooter
combining realistic gun play with
personalized classes
can i just say
oh is it gonna be four before um
this seems like a weird one to have tom
clancy
in front of is my first impression like
when you say that something is a tom
clancy game
i expect it to be akin to the tom clancy
novels which is realism military
there's the goggles oh sam i miss you
um the colors in this and like the the
whole xd the logo
i wonder if it's just a thing where
they're like where we can use the name
tom clancy we're using the name tom
clancy but i feel like at this point
gamers know ubisoft games i don't know
they'd have to tie it to a franchise
that's what it is just seems like a
weird one
those classes are represented in our
game as factions
each bringing unique gameplay and team
dynamics
every faction comes equipped with traits
abilities
and an ultra to complement your play
style and the fact so it's a little bit
more
skillfully each faction is capable of
hero shootery
that's interesting our factions are at
the heart of the game i do like the soft
style inspired by maverick groups
from across tom clancy's games and
beyond 3v3
from this inspiration we created new
characters
and gameplay unique to our shooter
could be fun and we'll continue to add
to this diverse cast
as the game evolves now while factions
help you define classic moves
we know to be a great shooter the gun
play
has to be our top priority yeah that's
fair
we have an ever-growing arsenal of
authentic weapons and attacks i mean i'm
sure they collaborated with the ch2
and i think siege feels great god i used
to love
like we've crafted so many attachments
so many old video game franchises like
splinter cell
and rainbow six vegas
players can mix and match any faction
and weapon loadout
you can swap at respawn to adapt to a
changing battlefield
personalize your faction and loadout to
be what you need
when you need it and i can't stress this
interesting enough
we are a shooter first
i don't know i i had literally no doubt
about that create unique opportunities
to set up nail-biting shootouts and
unforgettable clutch i think he thought
we were more lost on that than we were
personalizing classes guns definitely
basically our other fast-paced
is a whole new experience in tom clancy
gaming
we are super stoked about what we've
accomplished so far
and i couldn't be more proud of our
incredible team
we want to personally thank everyone
that's worked so hard
during the pandemic to keep the momentum
going on this game
we understand that it's been even harder
for some of you we hope that we can
build a community that's a place where
people can connect and have fun
and we're committed to creating a
welcoming game based on fair play and
transparency whether you're playing
casually or pushing yourself
competitively
the game's still in early development
but we're gearing up to let you in as
soon as possible
so register right now to participate in
our early rollout phases
thank you so much i might do that we
really want your input
so please reach out to us on social
media
i don't love um what when people
um and it's happening all the time
lately use
uh the pandemic in their marketing but i
also feel like they probably are being
genuine
um so my first impressions are find it
weird that it's called tom clancy
also understand why that exists for
business reasons um
looks okay it didn't blow me away there
was nothing in there that felt different
to other things
in that kind of genre that's my take but
there is another video
on the channel we have an exclusive dev
interview to learn a little bit more
here y'all you just got the first
tom clancy's and he's wonderful players
anywhere
i'm covering both his face and his name
i can't do that to you
okay much better all right let's do it
y'all you just got the first look at tom
clancy's
ex-defiant players anywhere in the world
right now can head to playxdefiant.com
to sign up for a chance to play early
and pc players in the us and canada can
start playing as early as august
5th until then wow that's a quick
turnaround game i would like to
my two very special guests kim wagon
producer on tom quaint says that's the
fine kim how are you
i'm doing great thank you aunt mark
rubin executive producer on the game
mark thanks so much for joining us so
funny this has just been people's houses
now
that's the world we're in so i want to
get into things
uh i want to get into some of the
details because this is a new look for
tom clancy
can you tell us a little bit yes thank
you joseph
uh yeah you know so we wanted to make a
game
uh that had at its core uh
a strong expectation of quality around
gameplay
uh so you know uh movement aiming
shooting etc
i think siege does that i feel grounded
actually i think most ubisoft games do
movement so smooth and reactive and we
felt that
that matched up really well with the
clancy universe
but we wanted to bring a very different
take
on the attitude that is i would say
normally associated with clancy
uh and i i think you can even see that
in our title
you know the the defiance correct oh
yeah they're using ubisoft original now
i keep forgetting
irreverent in rebellious take that we
think flips
the normally serious clancy vibe it does
yes tell us a little bit about what kind
of game x defiant is
at its core x defiant is a really
fast-paced arena shooter with a
reasonably fast time to kill
uh it should be very familiar to all
players of the genre
and so you can you know jump in quickly
alone or with friends uh you can go into
it with a very competitive mindset
and uh you know really test yourself on
that front i like sound of that the
number one
things that i wanna uh to say about the
team in the game is that
uh we're just we're ready to make a game
that people enjoy playing who's this guy
it's literally that simple what's
who's this man on his go-kart
i have questions about this yusuf can
you ask about this please
who is this gentleman what
sorry mark go ahead paul we want the
beginning of this game's life
uh to be very humble and focus on being
transparent with our community
and have them be involved in evolving
the game
i don't think we want to have any
features or parts of the game that we
won't talk about with
our community and there's no well maybe
the next game will have those
improvements
because you want it to lost forever
because it's free to play for years yeah
uh we're not going to abandon it and go
off and make another game after this one
launches
uh we want to be dedicated to our
community
we'll make some mistakes um but we hope
the community will trust us enough
it's a weird choice to even we'll always
own up to those speak about this
because to fix that it's never going to
sound genuine unfortunately
again at the end of the day we just want
to build a game and a community
uh that people really want to be a part
of
oh that's great to hear mark it has to
be very excited uh
now i want to get a little bit into
gameplay specifically that video we just
saw
kim we got to look at some factions that
are coming to the game can you tell us a
little bit more about them
i can so our factions are class-based
gameplay and we have four factions that
we're showing off currently
the first is the wolves from ghost recon
they're just reading scripts this is a
strange choice
higher health than the other factions i
think they are listening and they have
abilities that are shield-based
people are doing stuff from home from
the division the first is the cleaners
our fire based high dps assault class
which is basically the division which is
our healing
faction and finally we have the echelon
which is from splinter cell
it's our support faction they are all
about hiding information from the
enemies
it just hurts now our factions have
elements
they have passive traits why would you
ultra tease us like that you know
freedom to choose from a number of
different abilities that will change the
moment-to-moment game play
so on top of all this we also have
defiance which are the characters that
you can select
within those factions and every defiant
has a set
of skin so you can really customize what
your character looks like when you play
that's where the money comes in defiance
you're that's why your micro
transactions show up all of that for
sure and changed when you respawn in our
game so you are not committed to a
loadout as soon as you go into a match
you can change it pretty much
every time because otherwise how would
we monetize it you know you can buy you
can buy whatever you want whatever you
want uh but
but also that gunplay is still the key
that is what will make or break
the win or loss for your match
and i think the final note is we're
going to continue to add to this roster
of factions defiance abilities loadouts
and we really want to hear from you all
the people who are going to play
our game what you want to see oh kim
that's so great to hear that's awesome
uh mark i want to ask you now tell us a
little bit about the
different maps and modes coming to x
defiant
uh yeah um i could give you some details
too
uh but let me let me first talk about
the maps because
i love what our team has done uh i
really love our maps
uh not you know not only do they play
really well
so different is interesting and full of
character
uh they are all really unique in
beautiful locations
and i think this is an area where our
snowdrop engine really shines
and as we start seeing all of the maps
for launch and beyond
i think you'll see that we're pulling
inspiration from many different games
pretty much in the same way we did with
our factions
now for some details uh in the upcoming
closed test we're going to have 10 maps
available
uh that will be divided paramount one
big deal standard arena maps and three
linear maps
uh and then for modes uh we'll have
three different modes
for arena maps um that's domination
ring leader and upload and then for the
link definitely just reading
uh escort and zone control so that's
great so we wanted our first modes to be
very familiar to people
but also show that we can play with the
formulas
uh and so we pick these modes to give
players uh you know a variety of
gameplay styles
uh so we have a mode for people who like
objectives we have a mode for people
i like objectives that is me we have a
mode
love an objective i want a more
competitive higher risk
style of play um as well as the two
linear modes
for people who like uh a more
progression style
of gameplay uh and it's you know it's
our hope that at launch
there will be a good amount of variety
in both could they say when it's coming
out
i know you have said you could play it
plan on bringing new maps and modes
played early in the us on august 5th
throughout the life of the game
but i don't know that's awesome you know
i love everything i'm hearing you got
plenty of diversity in factions maps
modes
all anchored by good when it comes out
did i just forget it
can you tell us a little bit about the
team that's making the game
of course i love talking about our
development team
so we are led by the ubisoft san
francisco studio mark and i both work at
that studio
and we have a team with just incredibly
diverse backgrounds and experiences in
game development
now we've built this team of industry
veterans and we have a lot of experience
in making first-person shooters
um but on top of that we have i feel
like seeing production
processes that are helping us get this
game to a point
that we're really proud of uh so we have
things like feedback loops and
iterations that we do very quickly
we play our game every single day and it
is so fun
um and it's just helping us find the fun
and really emphasize that as we develop
this game
now i will give a shout out we have
teams all around the world it's not just
ubisoft san francisco we have tons of
other studios helping us out that is
true
we could not get this far without you
guys and we uh love the journey so far
and we're really excited to see where
this goes
moving forward so we've worked really
hard on this game
we're really proud of it we think it's
really special in the first person
shooter
genre and uh we can't wait to continue
building it
with you all oh that's awesome i
personally know i can't wait to get my
hands on it
and if you can't wait to get your hands
on it either you can head to
playxdefine.com
i am going to do that i really am i'll
give it a shot test takes place
august 15 pc players in the us
and canada head there right here man
register to play
but my takeaway from this is
i hope that's you know fair
um nothing about it really stood out to
me i will give it a shot but i do say
that
for virtually any new entry into any aaa
franchise
yeah just nothing came across as
terribly unique definitely a more
colorful art style than we usually see
in tom clancy but i feel like that was
weirder to me more so than it was
appealing it could end up being really
creative and fun
but um i think that probably most of the
creativity will be locked behind a
paywall being that it is a
free-to-play game so
not not super stoked about this one of
course the teamwork taught i have
absolutely no doubt about that making
games during
pandemic is difficult i can assure you
of that
um so full respect to to all of them but
yeah this one just didn't didn't grab me
uh
i'm always wrong about this [ __ ] though
so i don't know how the rest of the
world feels
i feel like i'm always like oh you guys
do all love it i'm sorry if i've upset
anyone by being very lukewarm on this
um yeah my senses i'll give it a shot
i'm not going to say from the jump that
i'm not going to like it
it just didn't stand out to me in any
you know significant way
unfortunately and free to play does turn
me off the
over mention of cosmetics just meant
free it's money to me
and that constantly bringing up
community thing
was weird i don't know why i found that
off-putting
like don't pander to me that much you
know
um so yeah not super hot on this one
a little bit interested i actually don't
doubt that the gunplay will be good i do
think that they will absolutely
nail that but uh i don't know that's all
i have to say
thank you guys for watching let me know
what you think let me know if i'm a big
dumb idiot and i'm super wrong of being
super negative
i feel like i'm just being realistic but
we'll see also
just ubisoft we just would love multiple
innocent
or rainbow six figures i'll take more of
that too
that would be super cool but but thank
you anyway
all right see you guys